so recently 100 thieves announced that
they'd be holding a warzone tournament
with the hundred thousand dollar prize
going to charity but soon after they
made the announcement activision the
company that publishes call of duty in
warzone said hey guys you can't use our
game and while it might seem like
Activision saying no to a hundred
thieves charity tournament looks scummy
this situation is actually more
complicated than it seems so let's break
down what's actually going on here
[Music]
alright guys you know the deal sub to
the channel like the video and leave a
comment below and if you haven't already
go over to twitch.tv slash the score
esports and give the channel or follow
we're constantly thinking of new things
that we can do on Twitch so if you guys
have ideas for a stream or a new show
that you want to see just let us know
alright so back on Monday June 8th 100
thieves announced a four week warzone
tournament series with the prize of
$100,000 going to a charity promoting
racial equality basically how it works
is that each week of the tournament
three different charities are
highlighted and then the winner of that
week's tournament gets to pick one of
those three charities to donate to now
something important to understand here
is that this tournament looked like it
was going to be sponsored or at the very
least presented by cash app now cash app
sponsors a ton of other 100 Thieves
content and why is that important well
cash app were the ones who were putting
up the hundred thousand dollar prize
that would eventually go to charity now
fast forward to this week a hundred
thieves quote tweeted their original
announcement and basically said hey
Activision said we're not allowed to use
warzone for the charity event
so basically no streaming war zone 100
thieves would have to find another game
to use for the tournament series now
right off the bat people on twitter
we're basically like damn that's kind of
scuzzy of activision to do that but of
course there's a catch that makes this
story a little more complicated than
that
soon after 100 thieves tweeted out that
they couldn't use war zone and therefore
had to postpone the tournament slasher
who's an eSports personality that tweets
out breaking news tweeted out some new
allegations quote 100 thieves was told
by Activision that they could run a cod
charity tournament without a sponsor and
100 thieves refused sources tell me that
a hundred thieves made the original
announcement without consulting
Activision likely to get the public on
their side end quote and then he
followed that tweet up with quote
sources say while Activision has been
unclear on the rules regarding hosting
charity tournaments 100 thieves was told
a week ago regarding the policy of not
having sponsors attached opting for
public support to sway publisher tied
one CDL owner tells me it's a shakedown
end quote so now people had no idea what
to think and social media was on fire
with speculation about what the hell was
going on here all speculation aside the
problem here seems to be cash app and
the fact that it looks like they were
sponsoring this tournament series all
right guys I'm gonna level with you when
you look at Cash app with a little
dollar sign above all the marketing for
this event it gives you the impression
that they are sponsoring this tournament
series which is where a lot of the
confusion seems to be coming from then
later that same day after they delayed
the tournament series 100 thieves CEO
nadeshot went on Twitter and posted a
video in hopes to clarify all of this
mess let's throw our own tournament so
we found a day that nobody else was
throwing tournaments on you know
throughout the last couple weeks and it
was Thursday we got everything set up
and we went to go to our partnerships
team for them to find money for the
prize money they go to cash app cash app
says hey we got a better idea
we're gonna throw up money but we're
gonna do it for charity we're gonna do
it for social justice we're gonna do it
for black lives matter and we're gonna
raise money for a good cause I said even
better this is great let's do it
and so we make an announcement for this
tournament and Activision reaches out to
us like hey whoa whoa you can't run
tournaments on our game without you
talking to us first and without the
information we're like okay so what do
we need to do to run this tournament
they say you guys can't run this
tournament with cash app you can't run
this tournament with sponsors you know
and monetizing the tournament that
you're running we weren't making money
from this tournament monetizing it like
we normally do with our sponsorships and
the content that we create this was just
solely a hundred thousand dollars was
gonna go to charity and so they asked us
to remove the sponsors and we couldn't
like ultimately they said you're not
running the tournament we said okay
we'll go do it with another game we'll
go do it with another publisher this is
fine so yeah according to nadeshot
Activision basically said hey you guys
can run a tournament with warzone you
just can't have any sponsors or
monetization attached to it and on one
hand it makes sense having a tournament
Series presented by the same people
whose name is literally written on the
side of your giant [ __ ] compound yeah
could be a little suspect
but as nadeshot points out and this is
why I puts so much emphasis on cash app
in the beginning they were the ones
putting up the hundred thousand dollars
for the tournament that would eventually
go to a charity and hundred thieves
well apparently according to nadeshot
they weren't going to make any money
from this event
now at this point we don't know if
nadeshot made Activision aware that cash
app was putting up the hundred thousand
dollars for charity and also Activision
hasn't made a statement on this
situation yet so all we can do right now
is wait until hopefully the tournament
happens and we see how this whole
situation pans out but what do we know
well we know that activision does have
legal grounds to stand on here i
recently had a conversation with esports
lawyer Ultra David for that don't at me
we did about all the DMCA strikes
regarding people playing music on stream
and he told me that that same concept
applies to video games as well so yeah
Activision does have the right to say no
you can't run a tournament with our game
and that's something that neisha
does acknowledge in his video it does
seem strange to me though why activision
would have a problem with cash app
sponsoring this tournament if cash app
was putting that money towards charity
if 100 thieves aren't making any money
off this tournament what's the problem I
mean we all love charities charities are
a great thing right but on the other
hand if I squint just hard enough I can
understand why activision would raise an
eyebrow at having a sponsor on a charity
tournament and you guys have to remember
it's their game if activision doesn't
like who's playing it they have every
right to take it away honestly if this
just seems like a problem created by
poor communication because I can
definitely see people reading that tweet
about no war zone and thinking that
Activision are scummy pieces of [ __ ]
even if that's not what a hundred
thieves intended and then from there
things spiraled out of control even more
when slasher weighed in with his sources
the good news coming out of all of this
is that we're probably still going to
get a hundred thieves charity tournament
with a hundred thousand dollars going to
a charity promoting racial equality now
we just have to wait and see what the
hell it is they're actually gonna be
playing yeah I mean you're right for
somebody that does read as much as I do
half of what I say is [ __ ]
gobbledygook half the time my brain has
jumped to a new thought before I've said
the first thing that I wanted to say and
then half the time I'm surprised what
comes out of my mouth and my brain is
trying to catch up to what the [ __ ] I
just said you know